y el momento de hablar con nuestro
segundo invitado del día en el marco de
nuestras entrevistas en la feria
internacional del libro en la ciudad de
bogotá ls dago garcía es libretista
cineasta productor colombiano está
estrenando su primera novela la verdad
sobre la verdad dado un gusto un placer
gracias por estar aquí en directo
américa de france 24 muchas gracias a
ustedes por la invitación que significó
para ti hacer la primera novela además
la verdad sobre la verdad que tan
difícil además fue que tus personajes
encontrarán la verdad o nunca le
encontraron no lo sé cada uno encontró
su verdad y cada uno chocó con la verdad
de los demás un poco la novela va de eso
la novela va
de hablar acerca de eso que se conoce
como la crisis de la verdad hoy en día
el tema de las narrativas es un tema que
está muy en la agenda pública y un poco
lo que se pretendía era a partir de un
evento que es la desaparición de un
avión en pleno vuelo y luego su
aparición sin pasajeros y bueno una
trama alrededor de éste desde esta
desaparición de este avión poner a
dialogar diferentes arquetipos de las
verdades que hoy en día en la agenda
pública pues hay un personaje que es un
policía que es como el representante de
la de la narrativa del poder hay una
periodista
el representante del arquetipo de la
narrativa de los medios son político y
religioso cada uno como como siendo la
encarnación de ese tipo de verdad es que
hoy en día conviven y que hoy en día
chocan y entran en relaciones
conflictivas en nuestro mundo
contemporáneo estos personajes pudieron
utilizar el suceso para usar la verdad
que le conviniera a ellos en ese momento
tal cual
detrás de cada verdad y esto y esto es
evidente no solamente la narrativa de la
novela sino en el mundo cotidiano cada
verdad esconde una agenda cada verdad
esconde una intencionalidad cada verdad
no hay verdades inocentes siempre la
verdad es es una estrategia de
supervivencia y como estrategia de
supervivencia esconden objetivos
particulares y creo que
parte de la de la crisis que estamos
viviendo actualmente está en que hemos
perdido el respeto por las otras
verdades hemos tratado de convertir
nuestra verdad en la verdad absoluta
desconociendo que hay otras verdades con
las cuales al hogar y con las cuales no
necesariamente alguien que entrar en
relación de
contradicción y de odio
entonces definitivamente 100 en la
novela este hecho del avión es
capitalizado y usado por cada uno de
estos jugadores a su propia conveniencia
dago la verdad es diferente a la
objetividad
yo creo que sí yo creo que la
objetividad es una actitud la
objetividad es una es una manera de
aproximarse a los hechos la verdad es
una convicción
y digamos que si son conceptos conceptos
diferentes aunque establecen relaciones
dialécticas porque finalmente el sentido
de objetividad con el cual yo me
aproximó a las cosas tiene que ver con
la verdad en la que yo creo pero
mientras la
objetividad creo que es un valor moral
la verdad es que es un valor existencial
entonces
son diferentes pero relacionados
viendo a cada libro y al personaje dice
que es una verdad que se construye a
base de mentiras que tantas mentiras
podemos encontrar en la novela si
digamos que
los personajes van siendo víctimas de
ellos mismos por llamarlo de alguna
manera porque por esta necesidad de
vincularse de manera vivencial al
hecho porque a todos les toca el hecho y
todos tratan de encontrar en el hecho
algún tipo de
[Música]
de espacio en el cual poder sentirse
como si poder sentirse útiles y empezar
un poco a forzar las interpretaciones a
mentir
y van siendo víctimas de esas desde esa
construcción ficcional
que terminan convirtiéndola en su propia
verdad es por eso un poco dice cuántas
mentiras necesitas para construir una
verdad y es lo que los declara los
personajes que empiezan
inventando sus propias ficciones y
terminan habitando sus propias ficciones
en el momento en que empiezan a habitar
sus ficciones esa ficción se convierte
en su verdad sabes que eso pasa una vía
real pues a todos creo que nos ha pasado
en algún momento decir una mentira y se
va agrandando y se agranda de iu y uno
dice para un momento dices como salgo de
acá como como como lograron salir esos
personajes o como o como digamos cómo el
lector puede decir pues yo creo que la
verdad puede ser esta o cree que cada
lector va a tener su propia verdad luego
de leer la novela yo creo que el lector
y sería y sería maravilloso y es el
objetivo pero no siempre el objetivo que
uno tiene es lo que finalmente ocurre
con el lector o con el espectador yo
creo que aquí no se trataba de
develar una gran verdad sino un poco de
señalar precisamente lo contrario que no
hay grandes verdades sino que hay
verdades particulares y sobre todo que
hay verdades que que no necesariamente
son enemigas a muerte es unas de otras
en el discurso religioso por ejemplo
hay cualquier cantidad de cultos
cualquier candidato a próxima se esa
dimensión espiritual y ninguna de ellas
es ni verdadera ni tiene por qué ser la
enemiga natural de otras y lo mismo
tiene que ver con la interpretación que
hacen los medios de la realidad lo que
hace el poder lo que hace la política
entonces más que señalar una verdad lo
que lo que se pretende es hablar de que
existen una fragmentación de la verdad y
que tenemos que aprender a convivir con
ella sin sin llegar a esos grados de
polarización y de odio unos a otros que
nos están dañando tanto nos está matando
al final de llega al cabo me parece muy
curioso y me encanta además porque esos
personajes pues algunos personajes mayor
principales los que nombraste en el
policía la periodista pastor religioso y
un político en campaña
unos personajes muy particulares como se
le ocurrió meter a todas estos
personajes en esta novela porque pues
teniendo en cuenta la realidad de los
personajes como son de los discursos la
oratoria meterlo en esta novela imagino
que mi historia y para rato
si digamos que la manera de congregar
los me interesaba
me interesaba sobre todo tener estos
representantes de estas cuatro
narrativas de las estábamos hablando y
quizás el recurso que
que apareció para poder congregar los
que se unificarán y no fueran como
cuatro discursos o cuatro historias que
no tuvieran ninguna relación fue
precisamente el avión de la desaparición
del avión porque la desaparición del
avión le interesa al periodista porque
es una noticia le interesan las
autoridades que tienen que tienen que
han sonado al político le puse una hija
dentro del centro entro dentro dentro
del avión y al pastor lo hice perder el
vuelo
llegan y él a partir de ahí empecé a
interpretar que perdió el vuelo como un
llamado divino como una señal divina de
que él está llamado a hacer entonces
como que él el tema de la aparición del
avión fue el elemento que permitió
congregar y unificar las cuatro
historias las cuatro narrativas las
cuatro verdades y comenzó además no
siempre uno siempre cuando cuando hay un
hecho tan también toma lamentable como
la desaparición de un avión y una
persona entonces no lo cogiese bueno
gracias ha dicho no coge el avión y pues
absolutamente todo este tipo de cosas
entonces también pues mezclará y como la
realidad del sentir del ser humano como
en esa novela me parece también que que
es una manera de conectar evidentemente
con el público dado usted también es
famoso en colombia lo digo por nuestro
dice internacional por las películas que
usted hace es relatando líos sin gracia
el colombiano john o'shea colombiana
pero tengo siete años bien 17 años y
medio viviendo en este país y cuando
viste una película de esas pues ahí me
un poco representado eso es un libro un
libro pensaba en que público una persona
en latinoamérica se puede ver
representada digamos en este libro eso
es un poco como cómo van sus películas y
sus producciones que van como muy bien
el nicho del público colombiano no yo
creo que finalmente este libro habla de
una realidad que está viviendo música
latinoamérica haciendo el mundo entero
digamos que el clima político que
estamos viendo hoy con la polarización
los populismos están exacerbados
con
las crisis religiosas
yo creo que es una es una realidad que
nos compete a todos es una cosa que
estamos viviendo todos que sabiendo en
el mundo entero y en ese sentido creo
que la novela es fácilmente
identificable en cualquier latitud
cualquiera que la lea va a identificar
quizás su propia realidad con las
variaciones que pueden tener los
contextos particulares pero sí creo que
es que pensaría yo hoy ojalá lo sea así
que es una historia y una aproximación
esa historia que tiene un sentido
universal luego podemos ver a lo mejor
esa novela en un futuro no digo ya
representada en el cine de una novela o
una serie una plataforma digital
no sé no lo descarto pero no es una
prioridad en este momento la prioridad
es dejar que la novela tenga su subida
como literatura que tenga su tránsito
por por por las librerías y por los
lectores como libro
y quizás no sé no lo descarto pero como
te digo no es fruta no estoy pensando en
ese momento de que en un futuro cercano
esta sea una película quiero disfrutar
la literatura quiero que la gente tenga
el contacto primero con el libro y
veremos qué sucede nada no no no no no
no lo descarto era algo que querías
hacer o digamos porque en una película
porque una novela la querías ya
incursionar en otro en otro ámbito como
la literatura por ejemplo pues mira que
esto fue resultado de una especie de
accidente
hace aproximadamente 10 meses me llamo
juan david correa de editorial planeta y
me dijo oiga que hubo soy anda de correr
al planeta y siempre pensado que los
escritores de televisión
desarrollan un sentido narrativo muy
efectivo porque tienen que ver será
todos los días con él con el gran
público
y creo que es esa habilidad podría
capitalizar se en la literatura en euros
pensado nunca pensado escribir
literatura en realidad no lo había
pensado no pero no pero que hay que
hacer pero me pregunto si había algo que
yo tuviera que pudiera ser el punto de
partida y claro los escritores de los
escritores en general creo que tanto la
de la literatura pero sobre todo los
escritores y audiovisuales realmente
terminan produciendo yo calculo el 25 30
por ciento de todo lo que se imagina en
el 80% se queda entre un cajón y yo
tenía esta historia que originalmente
quería convertirla en película
y le dije pues tengo una cosa que está
ahí que
podría ser el principio de algo se lo
mandé a él le pareció bien que a partir
de ese texto en que se ha tratado se me
acaba el tiempo lamentablemente lo tengo
que despedir pudimos hablar horas y
horas y horas porque de más me apasiona
pues todo esto obviamente trabajando
también en la televisión pero pues
lamentablemente se nos acabó el tiempo
gracias por estar con nosotros en
américa 24
estamos comportando entonces con dago
garcía sobre su novela literaria la
primera la verdad sobre la verdad
nosotros continuamos esto es directo
américa aquí en france 24
[Música]